hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for wired the good dinosaur Pixar 16th
CGI film tells the story of a lost
heroes long trip home while finding
himself on the way he's accompanied by a
faithful sidekick a loyal dog except in
this film the dog is a boy the hero is a
dinosaur and the yellow brick road is a
roaring mountain river the film starts
with a what-if premise what if the media
that killed off the dinosaurs many years
ago had actually missed the earth but
from a technical point of view the
film's most successful triumph is not
centered around the dinosaurs but around
the incredible environment in which they
inhabit the landscape in this film is
just stunning perhaps more beautiful
than any studio has yet ever managed to
render to the big screen and it plays
several key roles in the plot it really
is a character in its own right
the CGI world could be called realistic
but ultra realistic would work to be
more accurate and this is in stark
contrast to the characters themselves
such as Arlo and spot who are well very
stylized and neither could be described
as realistic of course they worked
perfectly carrying the emotional sort of
weight of the storytelling of the film
the world is actually built on accurate
data from the US Geological Survey
but it's the wonderful virtual
cinematography by DOP Sharon Callahan
herself a landscape artist that really
brings this world to life this stunning
work is coupled with outstanding natural
vegetation and cloud simulations Pixar
sourced the topographical data of
Wyoming and then use it to create 280
square kilometers of natural landscape
accurate orbit for the addition of our
Lowe's home clawtooth mountain this
complex world as complex as it was was
still able to be previewed in real time
on the animators screens at Pixar and
the final was then rendered in Pixar's
own newest version 19 render man
software
above our heroes there are a hundred and
eighty different fully volumetric cloudy
skies based again on government cloud
satellite data but also the special
accurate light-scattering clouds made in
render man the volumetric clouds were
so effective that the lighting team
actually lets through them to the
landscape below controlling the Sun and
sky maps to illuminate Arlo and spots
world this is a incredible achievement
to not use hand drawn or painted clouds
but actually to populate the entire film
with accurate volumetric clouds and with
a huge variety of rain and fog in fact
the weather actually gets baked into
every shrub and tree with the instance
geometry containing varying levels of
wind blowing movement this library of
vegetation contains some 3,500
simulations alone that's 20 terabytes of
data an animator simply got to pick the
amount of wind they wanted when adding
any vegetation to any new part of the
landscape but there was even more data
in the over 900 effect shots in the good
dinosaur twice as many as any other
previous Pixar film nearly a third of
these involve the river or water the
river was made from Houdini's flipped
water solver but as those water
simulation is just so expensive the
river was assembled much like a Lego set
broken down into smaller reusable pieces
this means that most of the shots of the
river will just cleverly reconfigured
parts of the same stretch of river but
those modular elements were made quite
separately from the foam and white water
spray which was actually separately
simulated at a 1 centimeter scale across
the entire distance sometimes a quarter
of a mile in some shots the film sets a
new benchmark for natural beauty and CG
while delivering an honest and genuine
story please subscribe for more behind
the scenes action I'm Mike Seymour for
wide
I'm done being scared it's good scare
you